hello and welcome to New World review
where I do everything in my power to
turn you to the dark side feel the
darkness grow within you hold it hold
that tiny ball of pure evil and let it
grow years grow grow my minion grow into
the powerful being you are always meant
to be hi I'm Randall I'm wife ooh here
to discuss episodes 10 and 11 of Hunter
hunter heaven a bit of housekeeping
before we begin I've heard feedback
saying you want three episodes or more
because they're many arcs of suspense if
I were watching this as it came out I
would see each episode week by week when
I review I watch one episode and write
my thoughts before moving on so what
you're getting is a rolling review of my
first thoughts on each individual
episode yes I could watch whole arts
before reviewing or chunks of episodes
but that would give you a different
outcome in terms of my experience on top
of that it gives me a chance to question
whether I would want to keep watching a
feech individual episode for the last
one I saw it's a strange way of doing
things but it works for me in terms of
the time I have in the week in the
structure of the episodes I do hear you
though and I'll keep thinking about it
I'm not going to change how I'm doing
things right now but we'll see on the
whole you seem to be enjoying what I'm
doing so I'm still going but feel free
to let me know by making use of those
handy-dandy like and dislike buttons
down below episode 10 had a particularly
slow start but built up to a wonderful
climax the sound design of this episode
was particularly wonderful so I'd like
to dwell on it a little the emptiness of
the space giving way to a playful
bopping base at really nicely underneath
lay Oreos rant and Karakas stillness the
measured nature of karapa cos decision
was echoed in the measured rhythm while
the jazzy piano double bass and
synthetase early Oreos increasingly
panicked voice and large movements I
very much hope that what we're hearing
here is Lee audios theme because it
would be so appropriate with his tiny
glasses an open shirt giving us that
relaxed feel of improvised passion just
did I vote for a second but it's taken
me this long to realize that Lee Oreo is
slowly becoming less and less corporate
episode 1 Lee Oreo had a full suit and
tie combo while I'm fully aware that he
couldn't really have maintained that
look through everything that's happening
it's interesting to see that as he is
put through his paces and his
personality and goals are tested he is
loosening up by necessity is being
forced to let go of the formality of a
doctor and take on
readiness of a medic and that's a great
shift to see because I'm that kind of
nerd it's fitting them that jazz would
become the style of his theme jazz in my
mind is what happens when classical
music is too constrained for the
musician to play good jazz you need to
know the rules of music before you
deliberately break them the audio is
learning that the rules of the exam are
different to the rules he grew up with
and this episode is very much him taking
those rules on board and using them to
his advantage it's the first time we
really see despite his big movements and
huge emotions just how smartly audio is
and I appreciated that I found tompa's
interest in lay Oreos behavior and his
analysis a little heavy-handed yes it's
important for us as an yes it's
important for us as an audience to
understand explicitly what's happening
but it's another one of those moments
where they're telling rather than
showing what's happening I would have
enjoyed it more if Tonpa had described
what was happening as it happened rather
than a large fairly bland monologue the
dialogue had a distinct teaching feel to
it and I'm slowly coming to expect more
than I'm being given the jump from
musical style to musical style of the
jumps from bright colorful art palette
to palette felt more like something
designed to hold our interest while we
were just fed information ultimately
what Tonpa was saying didn't need to be
so long it was a filler I do wonder now
whether it was deliberate filler rather
than trying to more creatively take us
from emotional state to emotional state
because the effect was that I went from
amused aboard remarkably quickly before
being caught up in forward momentum of
the next narrative be speaking of that
next narrative beat hisoka's Hunter
returned for a passionate reckoning the
art style the use of time the
combination of movement and stillness
all come together seamlessly in the
scene in a move I hope we see more of it
was filmic in its energy with the
passionate collapse of the flamenco
betraying the control Hisoka calories
and the enjoyment he seemed to
experience in combat with someone almost
worthy of him the great thing about this
scene is that we saw entirely why his
focus should be a hunter but it also
showed us why he should not by the end
of this scene the fact that he was alone
made me acutely aware that he would have
failed the exam if he had been required
to go through the majority rules
methodology he's not a team player I
don't think he wants to be I don't think
he needs to be it's very interesting
though that the group got Tonpa who
needs social groups to thrive and not
Hisoka who very much couldn't deal with
them regardless and a
ethically his so Kasim gives us a nice
break from the boredom of tompa's
thoughts telling us things we could see
instead if that was the intention I
don't think it was worth it but I've
already discussed that so I'm not going
back over it lay audio brought some
major energy to the end of this episode
and for the first time I legitimately
held my breath waiting to see what he
would do and how the others would react
his reasoning through of the problem and
his way of dealing with it were inspired
and I loved the way Majid Ani reacted to
the situation - I wasn't sure when we
first found out that he was simply
unconscious whether I wanted to be
inside his mind with him the further
through the episode we got the more
grateful I was that we were overall it
was a well-crafted episode with a great
play on word deed and thought onto
episode 11 Oh lay audio we knew you were
a teenager now we know you're a teenager
Greek drama has a way of giving us
enough imagery that we can visualize
what happened rather than seeing it the
idea is that whatever we imagine is more
powerful than anything that could be
described so allow me to say you you you
I'm not going any further into that then
this you oh this is probably also the
time for me to say that what I'm
watching is the subbed version of the
show I get the full voices of the
originating actors which is fantastic
but the reason I say this is because I
physically cringed at the use of the
word [ __ ] in this episode it's the
only time I've questioned how well the
show has aged hopefully that won't be a
regular thing moving quickly away from
this awkward moment I'm starting to
really feel the pattern of the episodes
the first half is the quiet relatively
boring half and the second is the reveal
the good thing about this is that I get
to wind back into the episode and get
re-engaged but the difficult part is
that I spend the first half of each
episode just waiting to get to a good
bit I'm finding I would appreciate the
story more if there were more morsels of
deeper content in the front half of
episodes I'm
distractible and while it's nice having
cliffhangers at the ends of episodes I
feel like they could probably pack more
into the front than they do it's more
about trimming the fat than anything
else that said I enjoyed going into
their minds it was fun and we saw a
musical return to lay Oreos passionate
jazz theme however that scene felt more
drawn-out than it needed to be so I'm
not going to draw this out anymore
getting to the second
the episode was great because we got to
see QR at work or at least we returned
to the Greek Theatre version of seeing
keyword work the intention is that we
never see killa kill he's so fast and so
clean that it's as though the job is
simply done the structure of the episode
with our strong man Jonas I say that
right Jonas Jonas Jonas Jonas Jonas John
s Jonas the structure of the episode
with our strong man Jonas was a setup to
show how lethal Kiowa is and this is a
good episode of why I look at each
episode individually actually if we took
this as part of the whole it becomes
almost annoying because we as an
audience already know enough about Keela
Watson no he's lethal this entire scene
is for the other characters to get
introduced to that fact that killer
comes from a family of assassins however
as a stepping off point if you wanted to
introduce a new person to the series
here would probably be a good point you
get the absurdity of the series in the
audios challenge then the seriousness of
it in Kiowas no one should ever think
Kela is actually in danger in this
episode not after what we've seen him do
if the head of the exam could almost
fall prey to Kela Jordan s never stood a
chance to think otherwise is to be naive
like Hisoka Kela I could just walk
through this that said his sock has
showed a flaw in the previous episode he
got cut killer didn't experience any
difficulty at all in fact at this point
kill was the only one I think could
genuinely become a hunter all by himself
he's cool calm sort of collected capable
childlike with curiosity and a lot of
other C words I'm sure I'm ready to see
a showdown between Hisoka and kill you I
realize I expect one I expect kill what
to step in
not because he's angry with his soccer
but because he's bored enough to fight
the card-carrying clown not to see words
today back to the episode at hand and
it's interesting to hear Jonas's desire
to touch human flesh
I highly doubt he lies human at all but
he looks so adorable that it almost
doesn't matter the man never touches
human flesh again except his own the
calmness of both characters is beautiful
and very clean in that moment the way
Eli's abilities are characterized is
quite beautiful and graceful as is the
way he holds the bag of heart
giving the moment of death to the heart
and letting Jonas see his own death is
one of the great moments of the episode
it reminds me of Kenshiro from Fist of
the North Stars you're already dead
except he gets to see his own death
briefly comparing those it's an
evolution of the form and a beautiful
one at that
rather than have the big talk continued
not only does he realize what has
happened to him but the delicate almost
feminine way Kiawah holds the bag is the
exact opposite to the beefy masculine
way we would expect a scene like that to
resolve if anything quinoa almost
manages to be more seductive in this
scene in a really odd creepy way than
the route managed to be of course the
intention in that case was to be
comically seductive I'm not talking
about sexual seduction so much as a form
of taunting in Kiowas case while the
route Steel's lay Oreos Hart with her
looks
kela literally steals Jonas's heart and
that imagery is not lost on me the
difference there is that Kilowog returns
it eventually Oh
and luckily magic tommy was alive but I
highly doubt he is now sir for a second
time because I don't think Jonas is
really worth it a moment for magic Hani
Liam roll the magic tiny memorial video
having shown respect to the important
characters we've lost along the way
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produces in general please do consider
donating to the New World review patreon
because the support of all you amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible if patreon isn't quite
your style then please do leave this
video a like share or subscribe because
it also helps support this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun then please do head over to
the discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on episodes 10 and 11 of
Hunter hunter this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time
done bum bum ba ba ba ba ba ba